تعرف الماده السادسه من نظام روما الاساسي
الاباده الجماعيه ضمن مجموعه من البنود
ابرزها ما يستند اليه قانونيون بان احكام
الحصار على قطاع غزه بقطع المياه
والكهرباء ومنع ادخال المواد الطبيه يندرج
ضمن هذه الماده وبحسب نظام روما الاساسي
فان مسؤوليه جنائيه قد تترتب على مسؤولين
اسرائيليين ويستدل على ذلك بحسب قانونيين
بتسليح المستوطنين وحثهم على ارتكاب جرائم
القتل ونزع صفه البشر عن الفلسطينيين كما
ورد في خطاب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف
جالنت كما ان هذه الافعال مجتمعه وغيرها
تندرج ضمن فقره جرائم الحرب ويستند خبراء
في ذلك الى استهداف احياء سكنيه مدنيه
ومقتضى في مناطق قطاع غزه اضافه الى تعمد
استهداف ومهاجمه احياء سكنيه ومرافق طبيه
ودينيه ومنشات مدنيه وتنص فقره ضمن موادي
جرائم الحرب على ان محاوله قوات الاحتلال
ابعاد السكان او اجبارهم على الانتقال من
مناطقهم تدخل ضمن جرائم الحرب وبحسب نظام
روما الذي اسس لانشاء محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه فانه من اختصاص المحكمه النظر
فيما يندرج في اطار جرائم الحرب والجرائم
ضد الانسانيه والاباده الجماعيه ويحق
لافراد او جماعه او منظمه احاله ملفات او
معلومات حول انتهاكات محتمله الى المحكمه
لتحال بعدها الى مدع عام يتخذ القرار بشان
اختصاص المحكمه في النظر بالاتهامات او
المعلومات
المقدمه